visit the c-span in the classroom
website in chairman of the Fed Robert
Bremner writes about William Martin the
longest-serving chairman of the Federal
Reserve and his relationships with
presidents Truman Eisenhower Kennedy and
Johnson this discussion from politics
and prose bookstore in Washington DC
last about an hour I just want to say
that I consider this location hallowed
ground there are a lot of bookstores
that take care of general-purpose
authors and introduce them to the
general reading public there are very
few that take upon themselves the job of
trying to introduce serious writers of
nonfiction or writers of serious
nonfiction and this is one of those very
few places and I just want to thank them
on behalf of all the authors for whom
this is such an important location the
subject of my biography William
McChesney Martin is still as Barbara
said still the longest-serving chairman
of the Federal Reserve System in the man
who in the late 1950s and 60s created
Alan Greenspan's job the subtitle of the
book is the creation of the modern
American financial system and Martin did
this by reforming the New York Stock
Exchange and overhauling the Federal
Reserve System two of the pillars of the
American financial system these two
institutions still reflect the qualities
that he implanted I believe Martin's
warrant life is worth studying today for
two reasons one is to understand how the
current Federal Reserve System came to
be what it is and secondly how to
understand the current financial reform
movement that's going on in the
financial industry and Martin's
philosophy about financial regulation
I'm going to start in the middle of
Martin's life to taking you back to 1950
when the Fed had been fighting bitterly
and openly with the Treasury Department
for four years in order to terminate a
system of controls over interest rates
that were established at the end of
world during
or to the Fed wanted to return to
market-based rates in order to restore
its ability to control credit and to
deal with the inflation that was
infecting the post-war economy President
Harry Truman and his secretary of the
Treasury John Schneider were absolutely
opposed to any increase in rates former
Fed Chairman Marriner Eccles one of
Martin's predecessors had lost his
Chairman over this dispute and his
successor Tom McCabe was in the process
of losing his by early 1951 the struggle
had escalated into a highly public
crisis involving emergency meetings in
the White House leaked memorandum and
collapsed negotiations one of Treasury
secretary Snyder's closest advisors was
the number three person in his
department Bill Martin Martin persuaded
Snyder to allow him to carry out what
Martin called technical discussions with
a group from the Fed and while Snyder in
Fed chairman McCabe kampala continued to
Duke it out in public their two
assistants quietly negotiated a series
of mutual undertakings called the Accord
to resolve the situation
the genius absolute genius of the Accord
was that it described the feds primary
responsibility which is controlling our
credit as equal in importance to the
Treasury's primary responsibility which
is financing the government when these
responsibilities came into conflict the
Accord committed both parties as equals
to negotiate compromise solutions
neither Truman nor Snyder really
believed in the Accord but they
grudgingly went along with it because
their preferred solution a cumbersome
interagency board of appeals was soundly
rejected by both organizations there was
a typical Bill Martin solution men of
goodwill would sit down together to
negotiate their differences in the light
of the public interest the Accord was
completed Fed chairman McCabe resigned
John Snyder proposed his assistant Bill
Martin as the six
yes sir and Truman still highly
uncertain about Martin's allegiance but
willing to give another Missouri and a
chance agreed to it so Bill Martin aged
45 with no commercial or central banking
experiences to run the Fed under the
terms of an accord which is
controversial not supported by the
administration purposely vague and based
on completely unproven assumptions now I
want you to envision the Fed that Martin
came in to in 1951 the Fed was seen in
the government is a third-rate agency
kind of like the office of the
controller of the currency today
whoever heard of it it had no public
identity and it will operate it under
the thumb of the Treasury for the
preceding nine years the interest rate
controls had been effectively eliminated
I mean the interest rate controls
effectively eliminated the Fed's
monetary policy feds most important tool
for influencing credit in the economy
worse yet the overall effectiveness of
monetary policy the feds tool was very
much in doubt both in the administration
and among economists in general one of
the elements that made the Fed unique in
the history of banking of central
banking is its independence from
political persuasion but that
independence had been untested for
decades both Marriner Eccles and Tom
McCabe Martin's two predecessors has
been defeated roundly when they tried to
exercise independence from the
administration and in addition while the
conquer the Fed was a creature of the
Congress it had few champions the
Banking Act of 1935 centralized monetary
policymaking in the FOMC the Federal
Open Market Committee located here at
the board headquarters in Washington DC
however Alan sprawl the powerful
president of the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York one of the 12 regional Reserve
banks that comprise the Federal Reserve
System actually ran the modest monetary
policy the
was allowed to do out of his New York
offices relationships with the
commercial banking industry the industry
that the Fed regulated had soured badly
under Echols and McKay was unable to
make any improvement whatsoever it would
be a true understatement to say that the
Fed had been magic understatement to say
the Fed had been marginalized by these
various developments I've told you that
Martin had no prior experience as a
central banker however he did have an
unusual amount of very useful experience
that would enable him to rebuild the Fed
from the top to the bottom first he had
a remarkably strong sense of personal
values he came from a close and deeply
religious family that preached and
practiced the biblical admonitions when
his two teenage sons began to argue at
the table dinner table Martin's father
required that in the future they could
only disagree by beginning sir I
perceive you are in error and then
laying out their argument is best they
could
if one son was particularly desperate he
could resort to sir I perceive you are
in gross error and then try the best he
could so Martin who had a very strong
temper when he was a young man learned
very early on that self-control was
crucial second Martin was steeped in the
history of the Fed his father was the
founding chairman of the st. Louis Fed
in 1914 he his father had served as a
living model for courageously opposing
vested interests building support for
the fledgling Federal Reserve System and
it's very beginning third Martin really
understood the financial markets and the
difficulty of regulating them he spent
eight years on the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange during the freewheeling
years of the market manipulators of the
late 1920s in the early 1930s
Martin was elected New York Stock
Exchange president when he was only 31
as part of a reform movement that took
over the exchange following the
conviction of Richard Whitney leader of
the
I reformed old guard and former
president of the exchange who had
embezzled millions from including the
widows and orphans funds of the New York
Stock Exchange she's a guy without many
scruples once he was in office
Martin was squeezed between the New Deal
reformer and SEC chairman William O
Douglas a reformer very much in the mode
of Eliot Spitzer today very forceful and
the old guard who still can try
controlled Martin's member membership
Martin negotiated a compromise reform
program the Douglas accepted only
because to pursue greater reform would
require the SEC to effectively take over
the exchange in 2003 the securities of
the SEC also forced out exchange CEO
dick Grasso before it could start the
current reforms going on at the New York
Stock Exchange so things haven't changed
despite depending on a weak coalition of
moderates and reformers and in the face
of dedicated resistance by the old guard
martin eventually implemented his reform
program i should mention that in 1941
after three embattled years as president
martin was drafted into the army as a
private and his highly unusual decision
to accept the draft rather than seek
appointment as an officer moved general
Hersey who was in charge of the draft to
say to convince people that were dealing
off the top of the deck that is
selecting draftees fairly it helps to
have some of the aces and kings come off
as well as the twos and threes another
quality that martin brought to the Fed
was that he'd already overhauled one
federal agency Martin was appointed
president of the u.s. export-import bank
the governance export financing agency
in 1946 the government had dramatically
expanded exid's resources but it wanted
to use it as a piggy bank for grants to
fund post-war recovery of its political
friends notably the corrupt nationalist
Chinese government of Chiang kai-shek to
stop that loan 42 year old Bill Martin
had to face down General George C
Marshall at the
I know mean theme Martin took a
different tack as CEO he pursued ex-im's
legislative mandate for creditworthy
lending and created a businesslike
financing institution that made loans
that would be paid back defending his
policies against state and Treasury took
him into the White House and that's
where Martin succeeded in persuading
Harry Truman to support his plans v
Martin had a well developed philosophy
for regulating the financial markets he
believed that regulators must understand
the business and economic realities of
the financial markets he believed they
must exercise great care in setting
rules that could undermine the
functioning of free market forces he
believed that innovation is the
lifeblood of the financial markets and
the regulation must evolve with it
regulatory rules must be as clear as
possible deal with the tough issues and
be rigorously but fairly enforced
technology should be used to monitor the
markets and finally he believed that
legislation is not effective in
regulating financial markets on a
continuing basis only capable and
flexible regulatory agencies are today
that would be the difference between
relying too much on the sarbanes-oxley
legislation and not enough on a capable
SEC now the question is what steps did
Martin take to create this modern Fed
two of his most significant rules moves
were to democratize the monetary
policymaking process
and second to strengthen the Treasury
bond market by restricting the feds
intervention he described his approach
to democratizing in typical fashion I
knew I wasn't the smartest kid on the
block but here I was so I just had to go
around where everyone expressed their
opinion and I just sum things up
through the years Martin became a master
at summing up some very heated
differences with the deceptive
introduction I believe we're all in
basic agreement here the staff was
continually amazed that individual board
members accepted Martin's summation
despite their strong differences with
him
a former FOMC secretary told me that
Mart
one the members support quote because
they trusted bill and they knew he
wanted to do the right thing
end quote Martin's ability to generate
trust by his honesty forthrightness and
coupled with modesty and unfailing good
humor won over his opponents throughout
his career to strengthen the treasury
bond market Martin persuaded the FOMC
that its frequent interventions in the
market up till that point drove
investors over to the sidelines because
those investors feared considerable
losses if they misjudged what the Fed
was going to do Martin wanted a more
freely functioning bond market that was
less dependent on the actions of the Fed
and more able to accommodate what was
going on in the market through the
actions of investors Martin decided that
the FM FOMC would no longer intervene
proactively to relieve stress in the
market but it would adopt a more
reactive posture waiting to intervene
until it became apparent that normal
trading activity was not able to deal
with the forces of destabilization that
those Treasury in bond and Bill markets
today are the most liquid the most
efficient in the largest securities
markets in the world
Martin's move brought him into sharp
conflict with Alan Sproul sprawl was the
president of the New York Reserve Bank
he was the best known and most skilled
central banker in the United States he
was the star of the feds traditional
meritocracy system and he occupied the
historic leadership role of the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York he had Abele
defended the Fed before Congress during
the debates over fixed rates he believed
that monetary policy should be made in
New York near the financial markets and
far away from the political interference
and in Washington he believed and
continued Fed to intervention in the
bond markets and had practiced it for a
decade Sproul actively opposed every one
of Martin's early initiatives Sproul and
Martin overlapped for five years and the
two debated continuously about many
fundamental aspects of the way the Fed
should run even though their
disagreements were often heated
they remain civil to one another and to
his great credit Sproul did not engage
in divisive politicking for his
positions Martin's debates with prowl
often produce better decisions but in
the long run spells resistance to so
many of Martin's initiatives and
particularly to democratizing the finiti
decision-making process cost him his
support on the FOMC on those retirement
Sproul Riley observed about Martin Bill
was very easy to agree with and very
difficult to disagree with Martin's
comment about sprawl was no one that the
Fed should be indispensable Martin could
be tough when it was necessary Martin's
leadership experience and free-market
instincts led him to his early policy
decisions but he wasn't an economist and
he had no experience in monetary policy
fortunately he inherited an unusually
talented staff of staff economist who
provided him with the theoretical
framework that he needed
Martin introduced new policy priorities
he assigned the feds highest priority to
fighting inflation and secondly
establishing a fully flexible monetary
policy under the title of quote leaning
against the winds of inflation whichever
way they are blowing inflation or
deflation Martin believed that stable
prices promoted economic growth in the
early control of inflationary pressors
limited the build-up of an economic boom
and the bust that inevitably followed
his own grandfather's green storage
business had been bankrupted in the
financial crisis of 1893 and his father
was broken by the experience his
grandfather he continued to live in his
son's home Martin's father and Martin
had that reminder for a long time his
young life prior to Martin's arrival the
feds commitment to fighting inflation
had waxed and waned but Martin made
price stability his primary goal
throughout his chairmanship Martin
believed that the Fed was too secretive
his first step is New York Stock
Exchange President had been to rebuild
investor trust by using his own
interviews with the press to get out the
positive story of reform
it's easy to imagine a clean-cut
youthful-looking 31 year old as a symbol
of a new day at the exchange and despite
his innate shyness Martin made himself
available for these interviews to
persuade the Fed organization toward
more openness he referred continually to
a 1923 statement the Fed policy was
easier to implement when the public
understood the feds goals Fed wanted
Martin one of the Fed had to make sure
the financial under markets understood
what the Fed intended to do
he believed in modest incremental policy
changes interest rate increases that
were well telegraphed just like those
going on now the Fed and the press are
conditioning all of us to higher
interest rates which are coming here in
coming more he encouraged federal
leaders usually Ellen Sproul to explain
the feds position to the financial
community and he kept but he carefully
monitored what was being said and took
much of the communication role on
himself as Alan Greenspan does today
Martin tried to keep the Congress
informed but this was no easier in 1950
than it is today
representative Wright Patman a die-hard
populist financial applied financial
populist from rural Texas held a series
of influential financial committee
chairmanships during Martin's turn he
was a fierce Fred critic held a suit and
had a special passion for criticizing
Morton regularly calculating the cost of
a rise in interest rates on the total US
economy and telling Martin that he was
the quote most expensive public servant
the history had ever known in quote
Martin was committed to appearing
personally to defend the Fed at
congressional hearings in a typical
response Martin would admit monetary
policies are a matter of judgment we can
always do better to get congressmen to
understand the feds position Martin used
folksy images to get his messages across
and he became formed famous for his
description of the Fed it's our job to
take away the punchbowl
just as the party really gets going
Martin was committed to reestablishing a
strong regional bank system and
estimated that he spent one-third of his
time on system issues
he took a strong issue interest in
selecting capable presidents for reserve
banks he encouraged the banks to expand
their capacity for economic research and
many of the leading economists in the
private and public sectors got their
initial experience at one of the reserve
banks most importantly he revitalized
the concept of the feds independence by
his actions over his long chairmanship
first he had to live into the Accords
concept of the Fed and Treasury as
equals
his crucial judgment that the bond
market would respond positively to the
end of the Federal Federal Reserve
Treasury struggle in 1951 and that
interest rates would not increase
significantly after controls ended
proved correct this success allowed the
Fed to complete the return to market
base rates and moderate but certainly
did not eliminate the antagonism of
Harry Truman and John Schneider Martin
told a story about Truman's feelings by
describing a chance encounter that he
had with the president at the end of the
president's term on Park Avenue in New
York City
Martin greeted the president well mr.
president good to see you
and Martin Truman turned around and gave
him one-word response
traitor was all he said so Martin
managed to stay under the radar and
still make the changes independence
cannot be achieved however without
taking a stand for that principle an
early example occurred with Treasury
secretary George Humphrey in 1956 in the
heat of a presidential reelection
campaign
Humphrey a blunt corporate CEO in the
most powerful member of the Eisenhower
cabinet told Martin that the
administration wanted lower interest
rates to stimulate the economy and if he
had any intention to continue leading
the Fed in opposition to the will of the
president he should just resign Martin
who had worked for four years to
establish a solid working relationship
with Eisenhower could only hope that his
effort had been effective
he replied if I am violently opposed by
the administration I will resign again
Martin's judgment proved correct
Eisenhower did not support Humphrey and
pardon and the administration backed off
from that point on Martin was always
confident no matter how difficult and
how strong the differences were that he
could maintain an effective relationship
with the president and with the
administration throughout the remaining
13 years of his term he never used the
threat of resignation when he was
disagreeing with the administration at
other times martin exercised the feds
independence in ways that were more
tactful and persistent than
confrontational as he did with John
Kennedy Kennedy had won the election in
1960 in good part by criticizing
Eisenhower and in the Fed for stopped
what he called stop-and-go economics it
was well known that Kennedy did not
approve of the feds policies under
Martin and for his part Martin was
deeply concerned about the
administration's commitment to faster
economic growth without any concern
about the inflationary implications
after a rocky start
that included a very public spat martin
found that he could not only work with
kennedy but also he could disagree with
him nevertheless when his four-year
chairmanship term was up in 1963 Martin
still expected to be replaced
Kennedy surprised him totally by asking
him to stay on saying quote I know you
don't always agree with what we're doing
and my people don't always like what
you're doing but in our dealings I found
you to be independent minded and willing
to speak up for your position there are
too few such people and they are what a
president needs after all above all
finally there are times when
independence must be exercised in a
confrontational setting Bill Martin and
Lyndon Johnson engaged in a four-year
struggle over the Johnson
administration's failure to deal with
the growing government deficits in the
build-up of inflationary pressures
included was a well telegraphed decision
to raise the feds discount rate in 1965
the first increase in almost five years
and it was taken in face of enormous
opposition by the administration martin
warned the board that a vote to raise
rates would show the world that the Fed
did not yield to administration pressure
but that their decision could quote
result in an important revamping of the
Federal Reserve System end quote
by an angry and powerful president in a
classic confrontation with Johnson after
the vote
Martin defined his move using a very
carefully circumscribed view of the feds
independence and I have to quote from
the book the meeting took place in
Johnson's simple office at the LBJ Ranch
it was a classic confrontation to
determine men both of whom believe that
the goals for which they had worked all
their lives were at stake
Johnson wasted no time before he went on
the attack you've got me in a position
where you can run a rapier into me and
you've done it Johnson accused Martin of
placing himself above the presidency and
totally disregarding his wishes you went
ahead and did something that I
disapproved of it can affect my entire
term here he finished you took advantage
of me and and I want you to know that
that's a despicable thing to do as he so
often did six foot four inch Lyndon
Johnson had personalized the issue and
brought the full force of his physical
and presidential presence to bear on his
adversary Martin admitted later that he
was shaken but determined stick to his
position and not to insult the President
of the United States in his quiet but
determined way Martin fought back
mr. president we were not precipitous
about this I warned you about it we
discussed this and you asked me to delay
it but we can't wait any longer
and another point Martin tried to reduce
any possible threat to John's presidency
by saying now you're the president and
I'm just
to worker in the vineyard way down the
line
I have no constituency I have a board
that supports me sometimes and sometimes
it doesn't in this they supported me but
only by a four to three vote
finally Martin said I've never implied
that I'm right and you're wrong but I
have a very strong conviction that the
Federal Reserve Act placed the
responsibility for interest rates with
the Federal Reserve Board this is one of
those few occasions where the Federal
Reserve Board decision has to be final
fortunately for Martin Johnson had often
used the separation of powers act as the
Senate Majority Leader when he had to
differ with an administration and
Johnson recognized Martin's position
another of Martin's conditions major
contributions was to establish the Fed
Chairman as the personification of the
feds reputation for nonpartisan
competence and its commitment to working
with the administration in the nation's
interest this is certainly symbolized by
Alan Greenspan today Martin was the
first German to be reappointed by
presidents from both parties he rectly
men martin regularly acknowledged that
the administration had the
responsibility for settings the nation's
economic goals and for implementing them
through budgetary policy and he felt
that the Fed should cooperate with the
administration's priority unless the Fed
felt that a justified jeopardized the
prospects for steady economic growth and
stable prices
the feds cooperation with the Treasury
Department led to the restoration of
market-based interest rates during the
Truman administration similarly its
cooperation with the Eisenhower
administration ended the inflation that
inflicted the US economy off and on
since the end of World War two when the
Johnson administration chose to ignore a
rapidly overheating economy and rising
inflationary pressures Martinson martin
abandoned his posture of cooperation the
credit tightening initiated in 1965
despite the opposition of the
administration crushed home building in
a threatened to liquidate the Savings
and Loan
Street before the FOMC decided that it
simply couldn't go any further one of
Martin's strongest beliefs was that
monetary policy had inherent limitations
and that it was most effective when it
was working in concert with the
government's fiscal policy martin
pleaded with the administration for a
tax increase to complement monetary
policy but the administration
stonewalled it martin believed that it
was a feds Chairman's job to speak out
on the principles of financial and
fiscal responsibility whether they
involved individual americans or the
administration and whether they wanted
to hear it or not
martin recognized that these public
lectures often made him sound like
cassandra and he occasionally lampooned
himself with statements like arizona
Artin complaining again but he's always
doing that in the end neither monetary
policy nor the tax increase were
sufficient to slow down the inflation
and it took another 14 years to bring it
under control
it raises the question why wasn't martin
who devoted himself to fighting
inflation more effective in dealing with
what became known as the great inflation
there are a number of reasons which
together helped to cover answer most of
that question but not all some will
never be answered one was that in 1967
in 1968 most of the economists at the
Fed and in the population at large were
Keynesian who were followers of British
economist John Maynard Keynes and they
believed that a certain amount of
inflation was the price of sustained
economic growth martin was skeptical of
this conclusion but he could not sustain
a sufficiently strong majority on the
FOMC to retain his tightening and he did
truly lead by consensus another reason
that was that in 1969 the general
population had almost no experience with
inflation in Martin's lonely
anti-inflationary campaign never
generated a groundswell of public
support finally he just ran out of time
his 14-year non
renewable term on the board ended in
January 1970 and Nixon's choice for a
successor Arthur Burns had made it very
clear that he would not sustain the
credit restraint at the Fed however the
Great Inflation is not bill Martin's
true legacy the modern Fed heads it
resides in the feds unequaled reputation
and relationship with its sister
agencies the Congress foreign central
banks and of course the administration
it resides in a strong market place for
Treasury securities through which the
government finances its significant
deficits and through which the Fed
operates exercises its monetary policy
it resides in the 12 Reserve banks that
enjoy strong local support among
industry and banks in their districts it
resides with the Fed history of
pragmatic policymaking that balances the
eternal tension between price stability
and sustained economic growth it resides
in a regulatory philosophy that balances
the virtues of free markets competition
and innovation with protection of the
public interest it resides in a
reputation for nonpartisan competence
and a commitment to the public industry
public interest enjoyed by the Fed and
personified by its chairman that is Bill
Martin's remarkable legacy and that's
why I titled his life story the chairman
of the Fed thank
[Applause]
so I guess if there are any questions if
I'd answered them all then we can go on
to book signing of course but if there
are a few questions be happy to answer
them yes yes they did
Laurie of the tangle with the chairman
of the of the New York Federal Reserve
Board makes me realize that we never
hear about the independence of the of
the regional boards or their directors
do they actually have a role or do they
simply operate as a committee of the
whole or why don't we hear about them
that's a good question
part of the reason is because the
independent banks have things to do in
their district probably the most
important is still the chairman of the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York and
they have they're very active involved
actively involved today in the concerns
about the fragility possible fragility
of the international monetary system and
those the the role of those those
presidents is to represent the economic
priorities and concerns of their regions
the FOMC has 12 votes seven are the
governors of the Federal Reserve System
including the Chairman and five are
allocated among the twelve presidents on
a rotating basis so it's very hard for
our Chairman who operates on a consensus
as Alan Greenspan does and is Bill
Martin did very hard for them to
maintain a consensus if they aren't able
to get a majority of the Reserve Banks
so so the it's it's really a collective
contribution that those individual
presidents make but the person who's in
New York has a unique responsibility for
overseeing the financial system since
I'm so close to it I hope that answers
the question yes a general question
about interest rates we hear of lots of
knobs that can be turned when you read
Barron's may
or some of the other things money supply
m1 m2 m3 dot dot dot M sub n is the is
is the fact that interest rates is what
the popular press focuses on really the
only thing that that the guy can turn or
can he truly turn money supply and in
which of the Fed guys had their ways of
their strategies of turning the knobs
that control our economy well it's uh
there are a lot of ingredients to
interest rates as they work through the
economy the Fed has probably the control
over the most visible rate which is its
discount rate which is tied very closely
to short-term money rates now but the
banking system is much more I should say
the financial system is much more
complicated than it used to be in that
credit is provided by non commercial
banks so that there are other ways for
the borrowers of the system to get
credit and the Fed oftentimes has only
marginal or no impact on those sources
of credit
the only chairmen who really was able to
make a singular impact on the money
supply was Paul Volcker who used the
approach of controlling the money supply
in the 70s to bring the end to the great
inflation that we were talking about but
during that time interest rates rain
when it's high short-term rates as high
as twenty two percent those of us with
gray hair can remember that those were
very frightening days but in fact that
was what it took to bring the inflation
under control and even today the
importance of that rate as it spreads
through the economy is more visible the
bank the Federal Reserve System has a
more subtle but in somewhat less less
blanket but a more subtle influence on
the money supply in terms of the bank
reserves it provides reserves to the
banking system and it does that through
the open market operations in New York
and that way they can either force banks
you begin to restrict their lending or
make their reserves more ample and to
encourage their lending and they do that
on a counter or cyclical basis so so
that's less visible but it's equally
important and it's a it's a more subtle
it's a fine-tuning kind of thing that
goes on on a daily and weekly basis I
does that answer your question
yeah yes it sheds are did much
traditional light I don't know as if
there's not a big line of questions I'd
like to pursue that line of thought one
more step okay one more step but then
one more step another number that comes
out is the time it takes to clear all
the time delay has also recently been
put in I could have met I and it used to
take and I don't know if I wasn't
following who was chairman of the Fed
when I first got my first checking
account but when I cashed a check it
used to take as much as two weeks before
that check would reach my account if it
was an out-of-state bank and now it it
reaches it reaches it the same day in a
lot of cases well I'll tell you what
rather than pursue that very far let me
simply say that we've drifted a little
way from from Bill Martin except that I
can tell you that the Fed is certainly
getting on board with the last changes
to necessitate a complete electronic
transfer so that even now we're talking
about three days and that will be down
to a day and probably when people stop
using checks that will be instantaneous
as so many of the other parts of the
financial system are so so it's coming
you know even better thank you you
opened a lot of interesting
portals for me in the real erosion and
the cursory reading of your book well
thank thank you
I think I guess one day yes I was
wondering if you could compare Martin's
philosophy with Alan Greenspan's and I
guess I'm not sure if is in the 70s of
the 80s of the Keynesian philosophy was
sort of felt Oh fell away I suppose that
the current philosophy is more in line
with Martin's philosophy but and then if
would you comment do other countries
other market economies have this Federal
Reserve and is it if they do I don't
know if you know this is part of your
purview and if they do is that what is
it independent like ours and how
critical is that to an economy to have
this federal independent Federal Reserve
right well you asked a number of
questions I'll start with the last and
that I can remember and that is that the
as I mentioned that the feds unique
contribution is its independence from
political it's almost complete
independence from political influence
the Federal Reserve System is actually a
private public partnership the stock of
the Federal Reserve System is held by
the commercial banking industry they
can't get dividends they can't do it
exercise it but nevertheless they do own
it so that there is a unique
relationship between the private sector
and the public sector in our central
bank which is not true of any other
central bank the European Central Bank's
have generally become much more
independent in the last 10 years
historically they were pretty much
operating under the thumb of the
government the British the Central Bank
of England has always been the most the
first most institutionalized most
well-regarded developed most of the
concepts in the beginning but then this
this experiment which is almost 100
years old now in the United States is
truly a remarkable development it has
many unique characteristics and that's
why it plays the role that it does in
addition it's in such an important
economy to try to remember the second
part which was comparing Alan Greenspan
and Bill Martin which is a bit of a
trick there are I'm convinced
there are many more similarities than
there are differences in that both are
pragmatists both try to influence
behind-the-scenes the government in
terms of its fiscal policies both are
very committed to free markets open
markets and regulation that accepts the
importance of open market behavior they
there there is one significant
difference and that is that as I
mentioned Martin felt a a strong
responsibility to carry the nation's
responsibilities for for fiscal and
financial responsibility and make that a
public campaign and keep that issue
before the public now I do believe that
it's possible to conclude that that
Martin might have been out on the on the
public platform with his concerns about
the deficits and the concern about the
implications of those for Social
Security and Medicare perhaps earlier
than chairman Greenspan yeah but I think
they probably agree on that and honestly
I think there was probably more going on
behind the scenes because that's both of
these men are very skilled at working
within an administration behind the
scenes because that's where they feel
they can be most effective no no I think
it was that okay good evening I have a
quick clarification than a question um
is a is it true that the Federal Reserve
has responsibility both equally to have
control interest rates and have full
employment by statute of Congress is
that a true statement I know there is
not an obligation on the feds part to
produce full employment there's not
there the employment acts that
humphrey-hawkins the Employment Act of
1946 make full employment and goal but
it does not make the feds responsibility
for filling that you ought maybe
highlight some of mr. Martin's conflict
between those two goals with regards to
his job well
one of the most sensitive aspects of the
Federal Reserve is appearing to be
indifferent to unemployment that is is a
almost has been a problem now Martin
made the statement that he felt that if
any one person were unemployed that that
person felt unemployment was a very
important issue and he sympathized with
it I think and and in fact he was when
he was young man was involved in
studying unemployment insurance programs
in various other countries he had a
strong feeling about the importance of
unemployment personally but he also had
a strong feeling about the importance of
stable economic growth and he felt in
the long term that to to put too much
emphasis on economic growth at the risk
of having the economy become
inflationary was not a service to the
people who were unemployed the
unemployment insurance that unemployment
generally during the downturns was a
temporary condition and the feds job was
to try and reduce that amount of
temporary condition as to as short a
period as possible
and you did that by expanding the
experience in the economy so I but I
it's a very sensitive issue continues to
be that today and there the the
administration in the Fed often see that
issue from different points of view in
your comments you you you beautifully
summarized the enormous importance of
the human element of the of the chairman
of the Fed his his role as a an
administrator and one who brings people
together many of us can can remember as
you alluded to that was during those
years that there's this enormous debate
beginning between the Keynesian zazz as
you're marked in the Milton Friedman
School in Chicago here was a man who
certainly had no particular standing as
an economist but how did he deal with
the the economic or
or the the community of economists and
kind of changed the horses that he was
that he was driving while all the
chariot was moving at full speed ahead
thanks for the question
Martin Martin had during most of his
term a staff member read all of the
economic books that came out of the
theory and summarized them for him that
was one source so he really wanted to be
as aware as possible of what current
economic thought was obviously none of
the details he simply didn't have the
capacity to do that but he he wanted to
be aware as much as possible secondly he
established a an academic research board
which was an advisory board which
brought in renowned economists of
various stripes around the country to
the to the Fed on an annual basis to
talk about to try to get alternative
views as I mentioned within the Fed
during his term the Keynesian really
became by far the majority of his staff
of the economists who are on the FOMC
and on these governors so that the the
and actually by the time he retired the
monetarists were were still in a
relatively early stage of their public
presentation they really weren't having
the impact it was a small school out in
Chicago around Milton Friedman in a few
other places
what and and in fact there were very
strong feelings anti monetary
particularly in the New York Bank and
oftentimes if a president of one of the
banks felt very strongly about an issue
he would direct his his economic staff
to do research on that and write papers
and make statements so Martin Martin was
fortunate as I indicated when he first
came by being tutored by three legends
in fed history of economic development
of economics I will say just a couple of
things that are that are important one
is that that during this during these
60s
economic models computer-based models of
the economy we're starting to become
much more widely accepted and it was
used within the Fed but Martin had a
problem with using that to develop a
forecast which then became a
straightjacket for thinking about how
the Fed should respond fed Martin
believed very much in pragmatism in that
you looked at the economic conditions as
they flowed toward you and you were
constantly modifying your position in
order to accept that additional
information that you weren't looking for
the money supply to be growing at X or
for bank reserves to be growing at Y you
were trying to do Ollie's and have a
broader range as possible of indicators
and I think Alan Greenspan does that
today so it was a mix Bob I think thank
you it's a it's a it was a remarkable
achievement and again we thank you for
bringing back to our attention a man who
really as you say laid the whole
groundwork for an institution that we
all think of every day today thank you
okay last question okay you talked a lot
about how important the independence of
the Fed is and how important Martin was
in establishing that I wondered if you'd
briefly address how the problems with
maintaining that any challenges to that
independence particularly as we look
toward a new chair in the
not-too-distant future I think we have
been fortunate in the last ten years to
have an economy which has been produced
a couple of soft landings for us I think
that as a result of that and that the
tax revenues and the government's
ability to plan its its budgets have
been less complicated than they were
certainly during Martin's time I think
that those conditions tend to put the
pressure on a president relative
the Fed Chairman and those pressures
have been a little less in the last
decade I think because of good economic
management because of fortunate marking
market in worldwide economic
circumstances so I think that there have
been fewer challenges during Arthur
Bernstein there were a number of
legislative changes that people wanted
to force some brackets around what the
Federal Reserve could and couldn't do
that came from Congress there have been
a few classic confrontations now between
a president and in a chairman of the
board but I I suspect that most of us
can't remember the last time that's
happened and I think it's been generally
because the economic conditions have
have lessened that the possibilities for
friction that's it okay we all want to
take proper Bremner for a wonderful talk
I'm going to hold this chair up here for
him to sit down inside books if people
will line up to my left please and also
if you'll help us fold the chairs it's a
great help Robert Bremner is a former
investment banker and management
consultant chairman of the Fed is
published by Yale University Press
online at Yale Books calm